President Trump says in new york-based
columnist who accused him of sexual
assault is quote not my type says the
President of the United States in an
interview with the political newspaper
the hill the president said this
encounter described by II Jean Carroll
never happened and that she's quote
totally lying
Jericka Duncan is here with the
allegation Jericho good morning good
morning Gail agent Carroll is a
prominent columnist for Elle magazine
she says back in the mid 1990s mr. Trump
threw her up against a wall in the
dressing room of a new york city
department store he then allegedly
forced himself on her Carol said she
fought back during the alleged three
minute encounter in an interview last
night she described what she says
happened we were even almost even in
height and downloaded Tice and it was
against my will and it hurt it was a
fight
Carol says she would have considered a
formal complaint against mr. Trump with
the New York Police Department but
lawyers told her the statute of
limitations had expired in her new book
Carol also says former CBS chairman and
CEO Leslie Moonves sexually assaulted
her in an elevator after an interview in
Beverly Hills also in the 1990s in a
statement to the New York Magazine
Moonves says he emphatically denies
Carole's accusation
Moonves was forced out of CBS last year
following allegations of sexual
misconduct
he denied those allegations as well Tony
Rikka thank you very much it's all just
just I don't even know where to begin
on this particular story but I think
it's interesting that a Jean Carroll
says back in the day she told two of her
friends and friends convinced her not to
go public with it because no one would
believe her that she would not be
believed there's the legal question and
then there's the political question and
I think the political consultants would
tell you when it comes to Trump and
these kind of accusations it's sort of
quote baked in right yes they're not new
allegation a president denies meeting
her back in the day there is a
photograph actually that appeared in New
York Magazine which ran the excerpt of
the president shaking lip earring to
shake hands with each in Carol and
than husband at the time they have been
face to face with each other he said it
was just something in passing to say not
my type is an interesting sort of denial
but well because it raises a question if
she was your type what does that mean it
is very insulting very insulting
statement